Uh, let's see who is joining us today from
the two Oh three area code caller from two
oh three.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hey, this is Schiff.
I'm calling from Boston.
Hey Steve, what's going on?
Well, I wonder, I saw your appearance on Joe
Rogan and I was actually curious if you're
familiar with, um, Chomsky's propaganda model.
Yes, I am.
Uh, so I guess I just wanted, you pointed
out to Joe, um, I guess that these companies
that kind of have a public image of kind of
being liberal institutions.
So I just didn't want you to kind of generally
comment on how right now, I guess this right
wing kind of, I guess you use Dave Rubin types.
Temple tights are kind of criticizing Twitter
or youtube for paying leftist organizations.
One in actuality, I suppose that's the image
that they're trying to put.
So in a lot of ways these are actually hard
right wing capitalist organizations that are
trying to make people think that there are
liberal to kind of get away with pushing that
right wing agenda.
And I guess I kind of want to get your thoughts
on that since you brought that up with Joe
Rogan.
Yeah, that's really good.
And I'm glad to have a chance to talk about
this more because, so for people who don't
know what, what Shiv is talking about very
briefly on the Joe Rogan program, Joe said,
Google, youtube clearly is left wing.
And I said, in what way?
And he said, well, you know, it's like they're
based in silicon valley and like everybody
there is liberal and I, and I think he said
maybe like, uh, their, their CEO is liberal
or something like that.
And I made the case, I wasn't saying there
is no way in which you could qualify youtube
as as left leaning.
And I'll say more about that in a second,
but what I pointed out is youtube is a huge
corporation.
Their primary interest and their motivations
and most of the decisions they make are financial
and they benefit financially from pushing
sort of right wing supply side, low tax anti-regulation
stuff.
And that, that's not super left wing.
Now I do think the one thing I didn't say
Shiv and I think is a fair criticism is that
there's a difference between saying youtube
structurally and economically is right wing
versus youtube.
Internal culture is right wing.
You can have a situation where you tube's
internal work culture or Facebook's internal
work culture is more progressive hipstery
left leaning, whatever.
And yet still there outward facing sort of
structural economic priorities line up more
with low tax anti-regulation right wingers.
And I didn't get a chance to say that on Rogan
and I think that that is an important missing
piece.
So while I completely agree with you, like
yes, the, the, the corporatists priorities
of these companies are uh, are, are sort of
more in line with Republicans.
Any company bunny is looking to make money,
looking to make money is not necessarily left
wing or right wing and the culture can still
be one that is a left wing culture.
We just have to pardon through it and have
more of a detailed nuanced conversation.
Yeah, and it's a good point.
I think
what kind of irks me about, I guess this critique
of social media coming from a, I guess these
so called free speech as kisses, that they're
kind of conflating the idea of social liberal
ideology with having gay pride with economic
uh, ideologies.
So
the other thing that's missing from that,
which I think is interesting is yeah, increasingly
just recognizing diversity or having anti,
you know, anti bullying and harassment on
the lines of homophobic slurs or whatever.
Increasingly that's just called being a good
normal person who exists in society.
I think it's unfair now.
Just like, what are you saying about the right
when you say if there is an anti homophobia
policy that's a left wing company, like are,
are, are you saying that the right pro homophobia
at a certain point we just have to recognize
this is just behaving like good people.
Yeah, no, definitely.
People are definitely strong.
Many each other in that sense.
All right chef.
Thank you very much.
Appreciate the phone call.
Thank you.
Okay, take care.